bon les seuils j'ai un chiffre là j'ai
un chiffre qui tombe il joue qu'on en
parle ensemble jeu qu'on en parle avec
les téléspectateurs
j'ai un chiffre qui m'a aulas qui m'a
retourné le cerveau
ouais leveaux serre aulas interview
sacrias sont achetés sortie qui dit que
pour 23 % des couples soit quasiment un
couple sur quatre oui ah ouais le
portable peut être un motif de rupture
va bien aussi à moi je me dis ah bah oui
ce portable gti bulls il ya deux jours
j'ai pas le temps et ça ça c'est le
fléau du 21e siècle un rsa sans rigoler
non mais ça et alors qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est le portable l'été c'est le
pire que ça pourquoi pourquoi les
tranquillement t comme ça tu es sur la
plage tu va piquer une petite tête dans
la piscine sur un tas de spectacles off
et tu laisses ton portable tu vois pas
les bénefs de avec ton portable date et
tranquillité dans l'eau tout ça qu'est
ce qu'elle fait à 9
elle se jette sur ton portable même là
tu reviens tu es bien va chier tu vas
pas devenu tackett baignade josiane de
la comptable
je connais par coeur j'aurais c'est un
fléau sans compter alors là il ya le
truc le pire le pire ça c'est le pire du
pire ça ça vient ça ça c'est une horreur
s'énerve c'est l'icloud ensemble des
checkers alors ça à mon frère ça veut
dire très tranquillement nous il ya une
bosse qui t'envoient j'ai envie de toi
tout de suite à la compta mais encore ma
femme elle est en train de faire une
quiche sur le fouet à l'arc et j'en fais
toi la cour à mon frère mon fils il en
train de jouer à forza et il est
peut-être en train bateau j'ai envie de
toi car les halls tout quoi ou frères
tarifs chez what
alors tu l'as cannes josiane par des
toules m'est arrivé de légumes moi non
mais c'est vrai que ça donne c'est
horrible oui oui oui attendait d'eux ne
nous est jamais arrivé
c'était un ami qui vous en raconter ça
bien sûr moi si j'ai vécu c'est pas
contagieux et pas de comptes à regarder
ça et moi j'ai pas des clones sont gérés
en ligne à cognac où le téléphone est
née dangereux que s'il ya des choses à
cacher moi je vous mais je vous mets au
défi et je vous mets au défi de fouiller
dans le portable de pathos mais sachez
que ce quand on cherche on trouve
toujours les à votre jeu pourquoi
retrouve quelques travaux alors non je
connais pas le code
ah bon
mais bon pour toi c'est vrai nolwenn
vous êtes jardin est ce que vous avez
une petite phrase sera parce que même si
vous êtes clean
même si vous êtes blanc dossier blanc
même si vous êtes un gala vous êtes
tranquillement galaxian galaga vous êtes
tranquille et ben mine de rien votre
mode elle trouvera toujours quelque
chose moi sur la tête de ma mère je le
dis à chaque fois quand ta meuf elle te
dis à la plus de batterie tu sais qu'à
vannes demander ton portable un moment
bien sûr hélas mon frère non jamais mais
là et moi et qu'est ce qu'on fait on
passe des portables à tout le monde même
des choses qu'on aura fait des mises en
jeu suivante au téléphone s'est plus
[Applaudissements]
jamais spéciales et moi je suis blonde
houblon moi les gars moi je suis en rue
gamal mois en les six confrères vous
faire maintenant votre téléphone en
recto et au verso c'est à dire que ce
que vous avez désactiver les
notifications poser cette question vous
écris à ce qu il ya marc un message mais
attendez on va voir quelqu'un qui veut
témoigner sur les bebop
oui avec mon mari je suis rien avec mes
photos de truites dans son appareil mais
oui mais vous vous souvenez d'être gagné
et la seule bévue que j'ai eu c'est avec
mathieu qu'avait alors éric connaît pas
l'histoire
ils ont été remis et missions et ils
envoyé à mes grands chefs à airtel le
truc se faisant passer pour moi j'ai
envie de me faire dorer le cul tu m'as
au nom de 18 30
oh mammy mammy d'une bonne à paris sans
pc par george buffet a répondu aussi
soir merci merci alors ça c'est fait
depuis
merci vous avez vous avez déjà eu des
entorses au bras
irrité d'accord avec moi jamais c'est
une base à jamais non mais jamais jamais
j'ai toujours toujours quelque chose à
se reprocher mais bien sûr je vois la
dernière fois yahia de soorts à trois
quatre ans j'avais pris une photo de la
voie là dedans d'un animal non derrière
y avait une meuf awala et baptiste
qu'elle a retenu c'est pas l'animal
voilà rigoler non mais joue sur la la
j'ai appris une technique que ces
messieurs utilise beaucoup on ne pas
avoir le vrai nom qui s'affiche bien sûr
allez rire mais c'est bien robert mécano
mal je suis moi je te rappelle jean
michel mr et mme été sncf ratp
pendant cinq ans il croyait qu'ils
étaient pour ça il ya des applications
très simples sur des réveils que les
hommes ou les femmes mettent dans leur
portable en fait quand on clique sur le
réveil à l'intérieur c'est là on cache
les fautes non j'avais une autre
technique
alors quand j'allais chez monex moi je
faisais styles tous les week-ends que
j'oublie mon portable
mais en fait j'avais découpé la doublure
dans mon sac à main et je l'avais mis
dans mon sac
papa l'intérieur portant sur neuf un
double fond de votre portable j'avais
coupé mon sac était dans la gueule alors
ça ça peut aller très loin
ça peut aller très loin qu'est ce cas il
ya un sandwich aussi dense que le font
pas
merci mon coeur est ce que vous avez
retenu cuisine alentejano son bouquet
[Applaudissements]
perso j'ai dit oh papa de québec et non
publique où là c'est leur paquet leeds
adaptons nous voir et ses potes
s'imagine pas comme ça à la haye les
minions pourquoi pas oui oui bah ouais
alors oui allez après lui à quatre on
peut tout le monde mais messi non a
trompé tout le monde
abbas est ce que tu es c'est moi qui
trouve tout le monde nous voit rien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sapin
[Applaudissements]
je
le portable quand il sentait que
l'animal était surtout michel drucker
mais tu crois quoi non le portable c'est
vrai que c'est très dangereux
alors moi j'avais un code je m'étais
orange info alerte consommation c'est
bien vous pour moi oui toi tu reçois à
leur consommation j'ai envie de toi
il peut se faire sur le portable avec
fallait que j'évite moi j'avais deux
familles oui enfin là on peut voir
l'histoire sûr c'est très simple j'avais
laissé mon portable ce qui est très bête
à la portée de toutes les mains il faut
jamais laisser son portable soit à dire
à la portée de tous de la sienne
notamment sa vie c'est vraiment elle a
pris le portable et moi je leur dois la
de la télévision et j'ai vu arriver
vraiment pas très bien et me dit tu as
reçu un message j'ai vu qu'elle est je
suis avait reçu ce soir mon amour je
joue pour toi c'est son expert comptable
et cyclistes mais c'est qui c'était une
personne l'actrice sait bien j'ai vu là
tu es assemblée mastic g12 alors
[Applaudissements]
il faut passe il se passe que vous
connaissez tous à vous l'avez déjà tous
vécu ça ce qu'on appelle un caillou
contre kamikawa
c'est le kent contre keynes alors parle
de non agression d'abord ça n'intéresse
personne en la punch aux deux médias il
n'a pas il abat pokam je pouvais pas
arriver
moi c'est moi je sors tous les noms à
part un nom mais aussi alors tu peux te
dire que mon antenne à 23h d'accord
voilà comment j'ai invité avec donc j'ai
vu la porte s'ouvrirait ça mais je te
dira ah ouais bah ils voyaient nouveau
mauvais goût
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]